2022 has been a special year for Porsche.
A year where we've reconnected.
A year full of emotion, excitement and making new friends.
All over the world, our community has grown stronger,...
...and while we've celebrated those with courage and a hunger for adventure,...
...there's always the odd bump in the road.
Thankfully, drive, determination, and ambition always win through.
We've been guided by our dreams,...
...your dreams,...
...and an inspirational legacy...
...as we broke records, launched a successful IPO, brought virtual reality to life.
And we did all of this together.
So thank you.
Because without you, none of this would have been possible.
Here's to 2023...
...and another year to remember.